I've been fascinated and by the way
Australia I've been fascinated by a
story coming out of Australia and I want
to tell the Australian people uh in no
uncertain terms that I am going to be in
your land in October I'm going to
Brisbane I'm going to Perth I'm going to
Melbourne I'm going to uh Sydney I'm
going to Adelaide I'm even hopping over
to New Zealand and I'm going to uh
Christ church and I'm going to uh the
other one
The Other Place Auckland
so I'm telling you right now you got to
buy tickets for those at Tim
dilloncomedy.com
I have been fascinated
by this story about a woman who
potentially
poisoned her guests at lunch
with something called the death cap
mushroom
the death cap mushroom I'm not even
going to try to pronounce the scientific
name
but it is native to Eurasia it was
introduced to the United States it is
the sometimes they call it a destroying
angel or something it is a mushroom that
is the most highly toxic mushroom you
can eat it causes liver failure
um
kidney failure all kinds of uh problems
Within
12 to 48 Hours most people that have
ingested this mushroom are dead or dying
and this mushroom looks like other
mushrooms like it has so you base I was
eating a wild mushroom omelet the other
day it's part of my meal plan and I was
going well I hope they this thing's not
in there but this these should never be
like picked and they should have nothing
to do with food uh Amanita phthalai
phalladise phallitis
I don't know how you would say it
Amanita
whatever it is but the toxin in this
mushroom
is not
killed by uh cooking it
you boiling it it doesn't matter
whatever internal temperature that this
mushroom reaches it does not kill off
any of these toxins okay
so here's the deal
this woman in this town outside of
Melbourne Australia about two hours
south of Melbourne Australia and it's
called Uh liangata and I'm probably
maybe not pronouncing that right
leungatha Liang liangata
Lee and gotha whatever it is she has a
lunch
okay
she's having a lunch she prepared a meal
that led to
gastrointestinal problems for Gail and
Don Patterson the 70 year old parents of
her ex-husband Gail's sister Heather
Wilkinson 66 and her husband Ian
Wilkinson a 68 year old Pastor in nearby
corombura
were also struck down
the Pattersons and Heather later died at
a hospital while Wilkinson the pastor
fights for his his life at a Melbourne
facility so what she did
and here she is crying she was uh
confronted by the Press
what she did now a fifth person who
attended the lunch was also sickened but
discharged a short time later according
to the times of London
Aaron prepared the deadly dish Beef
Wellington with mushrooms but served a
different meal to herself and her two
young children who are also at the
Gathering she denies wrongdoing this
week telling reporter she cooked the
meal for the best people in her life I
can't believe that this happened and I'm
sorry that they have lost their lives
Aaron said outside her home I didn't do
anything I love them I can't fathom what
happened
so she invites her ex-husband's family
the in-laws
they all come over she makes a beef
wellington pie with death cat mushrooms
the ex-husband invited does not come
[Music]
all of these people are either dead or
dying she eats a different meal with her
children
we don't know where she got the mushroom
she claimed she got him at a local spot
um
we're unsure of where she procured these
mushrooms she's kind of been you know
maybe intentionally vague about that
um the Press is hounding her the
international press who showed up
because this is a very number one
if she did it
and I'll tell you why I think she did it
but if she did it this pudgy mom type
from a small town outside of Australia
this woman looks like my aunt
the idea of of cooking for people and
killing them with a poison mushroom in
your own home is so intimate it's so
ghoulish
it's so you know
like
just it's out of the fairy tale right
this is like Hansel and Gretel where
they fatten up the kids to throw them in
the oven it's one of those things where
we we think of poison Foods as like the
poison apple it's a Grimm's Fairy Tale
Sweeney Todd you know putting the people
in the pies
it is something that captures our
imagination
and I think that's why people are
riveted
by this now here's why I think she did
it because her ex-husband had a
mysterious gastrointestinal problem
her ex-husband Simon Patterson
reportedly spending 16 days in an
induced coma with a mysterious gut
illness last year after eating food
served by her
Simon suspected he had been poisoned by
Aaron A source told the herald Sun
there were times he had felt a bit off
and it coincided
with when he spent time with her I think
she's getting off
poisoning people
and I gotta be honest
I like it
I like it because it's something we
haven't seen
this is a new type of villain
we know about munchausen's by proxy
where the parents make their kids sick
so the parents get all the attention
they keep going to the doctor they keep
making their children sick it's very
heinous
this is kind of interesting
there's this chubby mom
in rural Australia
who's poisoning our heart like she
poisoned her husband
and he stayed in a coma for 16 days and
he somehow made it out
and she might have just she decided to
poison her entire family with these
mushrooms
Kill Them All
because she never got caught this is why
she never got caught
when she did it to the husband they said
it was a mysterious gut illness
he didn't die
she might have been thinking to herself
maybe they'll all die
but maybe it won't be traced back to me
or maybe it'll all be some mysterious
illness they'll write it off as a weird
pathogen
but they were able to identify the the
the toxin the mushroom
but I think she thought you could just
do this I think she thought you could do
it and get away with it because she had
gotten away with it with the husband I
think she thought I can just poison
people I'll invite them to my home I'll
make them a beef wellington pie which
does sound good and and they'll die and
we'll just assume it was a great tragedy
and we won't be able to link it to the
ingredient that killed them she goes no
one will quite know how they died
because she's probably kind of a simple
tin
even though she's poisoning people she's
probably reading about these mushrooms
online she probably doesn't know about
the diagnostic tools that maybe the
police would have in a situation like
this or what this even though there's
DNA and there's all this stuff you would
think that she'd be smart enough to know
and if she knew she didn't care but I
think maybe she thought she was going to
get away with it now she's crying get
out the video where she's crying
she comes home
the international press has descended on
her home
[Applause]
can you tell us about the meal that you
call she doesn't seem that upset
I swear yeah she this is devastated by
what's happened
Tony stealing
and
Kyle you know what this looks like you
know what it reminds me of it's like a
bad audition tape when somebody and
you're looking at self tape and
somebody's auditioning foreign
she's not selling it here
and
it's noticeable
how not upset she is some of the best
people that I've ever met
girls like
take your time
that I didn't have because my mum passed
away four years ago and Gail's never
been anything but couldn't kind to me
he's wiping no tears from her eyes so
some of the best people I've ever met
they never did anything wrong to me and
I'm so devastated about what's happened
can you tell us to the community
and to the families and to my own
children have lost their grandmother can
you tell us why you've poisoned them can
you tell us a bit more about the lunch
we started with a salad well I can tell
you
fathom what has happened ah I just can't
fit them what has happened yeah you can
you can but Ian and Heather have lost
their lives oh okay has lost her life
and Donna's still in hospital and I pray
I pray I pray that he pulls through but
he won because my children love him yeah
can you tell us about the lunch I can't
fathom what happened I'm devastated I
love them
and I can't believe that this is her and
I'm so sorry
that they have lost their lives
she killed them she did it that's where
the mushrooms came from
goodbye
when the subject of the mushrooms cat
which by the way would have been my
first question
that would have been question number one
while she's standing there giving this
horrible performance about how much she
cared about everybody how about go okay
thank you put a pin in that uh the
mushrooms where did you get the
mushrooms first question only question
but let's watch her now she runs into
her eyes in the car yeah house or she
gets in the car now
now she's getting in the car
she's going to the grocery store she's
got to get a lot more mushroom for all
the Press she's got to get everybody
mushrooms
wouldn't it be great if she came out
with pies for everybody
[Music]
I say I didn't do anything I love them
and I'm devastated thank God and I hope
come on in let me show you how much I
care I've made I've made pudding and
boys come in
she likes it man she's got a dark in her
life she's got a Dark Inner life where
she's poisoning her family she that's
what she's about this lady
unless I'm wrong and then this is a
horrible character assassination but I
doubt I am I doubt I am and you know it
as well
she doesn't care she's not that upset
she walks away when they ask about the
mushrooms she knows she poisoned these
people I don't know why she did it but
there's something amazing about it
they're all eating she's watching them
eat she knows it's the end
and she's just sitting there with her
kids I understand why you'd serve the
kids a separate meal there's no
reason in the world that she didn't try
what she made
she didn't even try it those mushrooms
are fatal not even at high doses now
obviously some of the mushrooms are more
toxic than others I was reading about
that you know the doses in them are not
always consistent
because there was a guy that ate them
and then survived but this woman were to
expect that she did not try the food she
was eating
there's no way she can now why the why
would you kill everybody
why would you kill
that's the one thing that I'm hung up on
here and I don't quite have an answer
for I don't quite have an answer
for why she would kill but she wanted to
get them all she had the ex-husband she
wanted to kill everybody the ex-husband
his parents and their in-laws she wanted
to kill them all poison everybody and I
don't quite know why
she might just get off she tried to kill
the husband once we know that
wouldn't it be funny if it comes out
tomorrow that like it was just a tainted
batch of mushrooms from uh you know like
the Farm Stand and no it's not
these mushrooms don't accidentally end
up
this is something that one thousand
percent was a premeditated hit
and she wanted everybody she wanted the
husband
and we talk about this thing on the
patreon where a guy shoots his wife it's
not a true crime podcast right now but
it's the summer and people act up this
is what happens in the summer it gets
hot out people act up people this guy in
Orange County shot his wife we talked
about that on the patreon this woman
poisoned her family people start when it
gets hot out people get wacky and people
start doing crazy things
I get it
this is it's such a fascinating story to
me I want to know how they're going to
prove it if they're going to get like if
they're gonna arrest her if they're
gonna formally charge her if they're
going to be able to link this
they got to figure out where she got
these mushrooms but
it is Australia so I don't exactly know
the steps that would be different from
had this happened in uh America
but
this sort of thing doesn't happen here
one lingatha resident told the newspaper
Monday
but this wasn't the first time her
cookie made someone sick and then they
talk about the husband
he wrote about the element on Facebook
listen to what this guy wrote
I collapsed at home then was in an
induced coma for 16 days through which I
had three Emergency Operations mainly on
my small intestine plus an additional
planned operation he reportedly wrote my
family were asked to come and say
goodbye to me twice as I was not
expected to live
can you imagine this chubby going
in there twice
and then it's still the and then he
still comes back
Patterson suspected his unforeseen
illness had been linked to eating
nightshades a family of plants that
includes Tomatoes potatoes and peppers
all nightshade vegetables contain
alkaloids like solanine a chemical that
can be toxic in high concentrations
but how much eggplant are you
eating
there's no way she's doing this
this is a new archetype of murderer a
kind of cuddly you know she looks like a
koala bear and she's just poisoning
people with natural poisons through food
because if you use an agent that's a
chemical agent that's easily
identifiable you can get caught what
she's doing
which is very interesting
is she is going out and finding things
where
they are highly toxic in the right dose
and trying to get people and I just
don't know what snapped in her head
while she wanted to do everybody at once
why not one at a time but she might have
figured she might have said I may get
quad for this one I got to do them all
I got to do them all I gotta get my
husband his family and there's more to
this story than what we're knowing
there's something there's something else
going on here and it it's been keeping
me up at nights I want to talk to this
woman I want her on my show by the way
lizzo they're not letting her they're
taking out of taking her out of
contention for the Super Bowl halftime
show
they're not letting her be and you know
who's doing it now Dylan Mulvaney and
she's doing and this is what's really
offensive she's doing lizzo songs with
the fat black dancers
so Dylan Mulvaney's gonna go out and go
why a man great till he got a beer and
with the fat black that's not right
but this woman in Australia I
I want to talk to her the crocodile
tears are fake it's this is she did this
and I want to know why she wanted to get
rid she's been around for a
while poisoning people
it's got to be so interesting to make a
meal and try to kill someone with it
it really is
kind of a ghoulish
thing and like is it wrong for me to say
that I kind of like
I kind of am interested in this woman a
little bit like I want to know about her
she obviously has some real problems
but to me she's more interesting than
anybody at the Variety young Hollywood
power Summit she's not more attractive
but she is more interesting to me
because people that deal in uh poisons
like that and will kill a bunch of
people with a pie
for example
are some of the most they're just
villainous in a way that's truly
terrifying and Suburban you know
all these Suburban villains the Gilgo
Beach killer this this is the
summer of the suburbs you know we all
expected there to be a lot of crime in
the cities December and I'm sure uh
people are getting thrown in front of
trains and people getting beheaded but I
don't have the time to go on the NYPD
blotter and look all the time but that
always happens gunshots always you know
rise but this summer The truly
interesting cases have been of like kind
of like Suburban Pool and Patio types
having these Dark Inner lives and
killing people and it's very very uh
fascinating to me these are always the
ones that get you
it's the guy or the mom in their
mid-size crossover hybrid SUV they go
into a gas station they buy a
bottle of water you stand right next to
them maybe you work in the same building
as them you see them uh online at uh the
grocery store and you think nothing of
it but
they can only get off by killing people
or thinking about killing people she
probably thought about this day in and
day out until she actually made it
happen
and I I wanna I want them to never
obviously she did the wrong thing but I
also want them to be like
I want this to unravel a little bit I
wanna
because you know she's probably tried
this a bunch of times or probably didn't
work she probably tried it with other
things
how great would it be if she tried to
kill like right comp but his stomach was
too strong
this is actually good listen to me this
is fine I enjoyed this
it would be amazing if it didn't affect
anyone
but it it it it killed everyone so we're
going to keep tabs on that story
uh when I'm in Australia if there was
any way for me to meet this woman not
eat with her but if there's any way for
me to meet I'd love to meet her
I'd love to talk with her I'd love to
have her on my show I'm a sympathetic
hearer I do understand
I love uh cooking I love the hospitality
I love dinner parties I understand
things go left it's not always your
fault
um I have a lot of empathy for her I've
entertained and not everything is the
way I'd want it to be so to someone like
this I say like I get it and I'm a
sympathetic eater to you I want to know
why you did it